[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing some preliminary concepts
in this energy methods chapter and today
we'll be moving on to another very very
important concept
which pervades through
all of our discussions all our later
discussions and that is
the concept of virtual displacement so
this definition of virtual displacement
that i have pointed out here
which i've written up here is actually a
quotation
from a very famous book called classical
mechanics by
goldstein pool and sofco which is quite
popular among physics undergraduate
students
we are not going to use anything else
from that book
but if you are interested you may take a
look but this particular
definition of virtual displacement is
given in a very nice fashion so i took
it from there
all right so what it says here is that
a virtual infinitesimal displacement
okay so please note that although i am
i i've mentioned it to be virtual
displacement here what
we had what uh what what that book
discusses
is really the virtual infinite symbol
displacement and
uh we'll see uh you know in a more
concrete fashion
what's the difference between these two
okay so virtually intentional
displacement of the system
it refers to a change in the
configuration of the system
as a result of any arbitrary
infinitesimal change of the coordinates
but when we're doing this change we have
to be
very much consistent with the forces
that are imposed on the system as well
as
the constraints that are imposed on the
system so this is very very
important that we respect the forces
and the constraints so a little
discussion about respecting the
constraints
as far as our
discussions of admissible paths was
concerned we have already had in our
previous
lecture so again we encountered this
important thing that we have to respect
the forces and constraints
all right uh now
uh what is the difference between this
virtual displacement and a real
displacement
so that part is mentioned here so this
displacement is called virtual
to distinguish it from an actual
displacement of the system
which occurs in a time interval dt
during which the forces and constraints
may be changing
so when we are talking about an actual
displacement okay so when we are talking
about an actual displacement
we do allow for the forces and
constraints to be changing
in a little interval dt but when we are
considering a virtual displacement we
are
we are talking about a particular
instant t
the time t uh at which the forces and
constraints
um do not change okay
so written in this fashion it seems
like uh i mean quite a complicated thing
okay uh so it is true that there are
certain
uh subtleties involved and let's see
uh if we can break down these uh things
in a in a step-by-step fashion to
understand
how really a virtual displacement can be
actually realized
okay how can we bring about or how can
we actually
think of such a virtual displacement in
a step-by-step fashion
so the first step towards that is uh
is that because we are indeed talking
about
the changes in the coordinates of the
system at a given instant time
at a given instant of time t so the
first thing that we do when we want to
realize a virtual displacement
is to freeze time okay we freeze time
and this is uh this is the part
where you really go into that virtual
domain
okay so if you're if you're tracking the
evolution of a system
as time progresses you are actually
looking at the actual displacement the
actual changes in configuration of the
system
the moment you freeze time and yet allow
the configurations to change
you are in the virtual domain this is
the most
important thing to note okay
so once you have frozen time you
consider
paths in the configuration space okay so
considered
parts in configuration space
corresponding
to some variable
t dash which
mind you is strictly not time
okay so this t dash is just some
arbitrary scalar variable
and it is uh it is anything but time
because
uh we would be varying t dash but note
that we have already frozen time so
because t dash is varying
and e is frozen t the time is frozen
so t dash is certainly not time okay
this is very very important again
all right and then we restrict to paths
which are admissible that is we must
respect the constraints of the system
if we restrict to parts which are
admissible
restrict to admissible paths
you see now why we had to make such a
big deal about defining
those preliminary concepts in such a
clear-cut fashion in the previous
lecture
okay so each of these things the
admissible path
all of these things have a very very
specific well-defined meaning
so i urge you that if you have not seen
the previous lecture
you please go through it in proper
detail all right
so now that we know how to realize this
thing this this virtual displacement
uh can we take a more concrete example
to perhaps see what is really
going on and in order to understand this
in a concrete fashion i think
it's best to consider the simplest of
mechanical systems which is a single
particle
uh traveling along a certain direction
let's say
that it is moving along the x direction
and
let's see what happens to it okay
so let me go to the next
slide here okay
so what i'll do is
[Music]
okay so let's say
our particle is moving along the x
direction
and it is moving along the x direction
uh
so it is occupying different positions x
up
as time progresses so what we'll do is
we'll say that uh
let this be the time axis
and let this be the x-axis
okay so since x is a function of time
that is why we put x along this
vertical axis and t is along this so
please note that this t
is very much time okay this is not the t
dash we come to the t dash part so
now this particle is
[Music]
is moving here so that is let us depict
it like this
something like this okay so as time
progresses
so for corresponding to each time it has
a certain x
okay so different different points in
time it has a certain x no big deal you
are all familiar with this
now we wish to talk about the virtual
displacement
the first step as we had discussed in
the previous page
was to freeze time so we do that
okay so we freeze time so suppose
we consider this t is equal to t naught
at this t equal to t naught we freeze
time so
at that moment
this has a certain value okay
this has a certain value
so that is the value x at t is equal to
t
naught now you see
we want to explore
the changes in x respecting whatever the
constraints may be
on the system that are present
at that time t is equal to t naught okay
because we have frozen time
so whatever constraints were present
even if those constants were time
changing
but what whatever the the situation with
the constants was
at time t equal to t naught we have to
respect those constraints
and respecting those constants we can
explore the variations
in x but now looking at this diagram
how can we change x
okay we have we want to keep on changing
x corresponding to some real variable t
dash so
i mean we have i mean we are running
short of directions now because
you can't move along this direction
because that would mean that would be
unfreezing time again but we have to we
have to keep time frozen
so we have to remain on this thing okay
we have to remain on this thing
and you have to keep on changing x now
uh
please don't think that i mean
of course in a certain sense what what
what you can say is that this particle
can move like that
but what is the
other variable what is the the
independent variable that we are that is
changing here
so in this particular way of looking at
the
axis it is not possible to depict it so
we have to go to a
three-dimensional version of this let's
see if we can
do that so what we'll do is
we'll take our time axis like this
this is our time axis and let this be
the
x axis now things will become clearer
and now you think of
another axis okay think of another axis
like this
so what is this axis this is our
t dash axis
this is e this is x
this is our t dash now you see
uh and let us of course uh
on this explain let us depict for once
the actual path that we were considering
it was something like this so this is
basically uh
this thing is just drawn here okay i
hope it is clear
so and what we had done here
is basically to take this point
is equal to t naught and
we had considered this point here
okay and now we want to explore the
variations in
x how can we do that
well what we'll do is
we'll vary this t dash and we will
consider
the variations in x corresponding to
such variations
in t dash so basically what we are going
to do
is we are going to make or plot out
the changes in x up
in a plane which is parallel to this
e dash x plane i repeat
we are going to depict the
the path of this
x of this particle path means uh
tracking out the various configurations
or positions of this particle
or changes in x all of these are
equivalent things to say
corresponding to changes in t dash okay
so uh let's say that
we and and please note that we are
starting out from this point
and this point is what this point
corresponds to t dash
is equal to zero okay so
let's start out from this and maybe
track out
a path like this i repeat
this point here it depicts
t dash equal to zero okay
and then t dash may be increasing
corresponding to which x is also
changing values okay so and this
this curve that i have drawn here this
path that i have drawn here
it is in a plane which is parallel to
the t
dash x plane it is very very important
to note
that when we are changing this x here
we are not at all deviating from this
equal to t naught okay so if you if you
can imagine
a plane here okay you can imagine such a
plane
maybe i can draw it here
okay
so that plane on that plane this t equal
to t naught
is a constant which is which is how we
are respecting the
the first step that time is frozen okay
but that does not mean that t dash
cannot change e dash is very much
varying
x is changing along with it so this blue
path that we see here that is a virtual
displacement
okay so any any change in configuration
from here
to here okay from here to here
here so as we go along that that those
will be
virtual displacements so we have to
consider now the concept of
virtual infinity symbol displacement all
right
uh you also please note that uh
at x corresponding to
t that is the time equal to t naught
is very much equal to x corresponding to
t dash equal to zero okay if you
understand this a lot of it
a lot of the things you will understand
okay
so let us consider the virtual
displacement of the particle
at any time t dash okay
so
virtual displacement of the particle
and any e dash
so let us depict that virtual
displacement by u
so x e dash
minus x
e dash equal to 0 okay so after this
point i will just write
x corresponding to 0
now this thing
it can be taylor expanded about
zero
okay so as i mentioned whenever i'm
writing x of zero i basically mean
x at t dash equal to zero which of
course is equal to
x at equal to t naught okay
i'm not repeating uh in every step uh
that's
those statements so uh
in the next step i'm going to tailor
expand this
x of 0 plus
t dash uh i can write this as minus 0
because all right let me write that so
that divided by factorial 1 which is
just 1
then d x d
t dash with
evaluated at t dash equal to 0
plus half
t dash minus 0
where d x squared
d e dash square evaluated
at t dash equal to 0
plus higher order terms and then
minus x of 0 which is also present here
in the previous step you see this x of 0
cancels with that x of 0
so ultimately what we are left with is
this term here and this term here and
we can write this using the delta
operator
in the language of calculus of
variations okay
so you think about it
for a second it'll make sense okay
i'm not asking you to make formal
mathematical sense out of it
but just try to make sense of it uh
by drawing some analogies with our
previous discussions
uh especially with what we uh what we
were talking about in our
in our previous lecture uh or rather in
our first lecture
uh uh or sorry
the first chapter on calculus of
variations
so you see this delta u
[Music]
this is the first variation of of
u is the second variation of u
and uh we have to use this kind of a
depiction
okay it makes sense here because
uh of course i have to write this higher
order terms here
i'm not writing explicitly so this kind
of a depiction it makes sense here
because you note that the original
independent variable of our problem
what is the original independent
variable of our problem it is the time t
that we have frozen in time okay that we
have frozen that we are not
changing so we are we are exploring
changes in the position of the particle
without changing the independent
variable
and that is exactly what this kind of
the
delta operator it denotes okay so you go
back to our discussions in our calculus
of variations
where we made a strict distinction
between
d y and delta y
okay so d y is always accompanied
by changes in the independent variable
which is d
x but delta y is changes in y
keeping the x the independent variable
constant
in that in those discussions our
independent variable was x
here the independent variable is t the
actual independent variable is t
and uh it is x which is actually
corresponding to what was y
in those discussions okay so uh
you understand that why i hope you all
understand why this
delta operator the the variational
operator it makes sense here
okay now very importantly you note that
when our t dash is indeed very small
okay so when
t dash
is very small
this entire u that is more or less
uh properly captured by this
delta u of course a little bit of
difference will be there because we are
not
considering this higher order terms but
u will be approximated well approximated
by this delta u provided our t
dash is very small so the this basically
what we are saying is that t dash minus
0
is very very small so
u is well approximated
in such a situation u is well
approximated
by only the first term which is delta u
and it is this delta u which here you
can think of
as the virtual infinite signal
displacement which we are talking about
in our definition
okay uh all right so so
now i i know uh even from my own
experience
that usually when we talk about virtual
displacements
um in in terms like in hand waving terms
uh that is often done in our
undergraduate classes
so it always leaves some sort of doubt
or confusion in our mind
that what really is the difference
with the actual displacements so with
this discussion i hope
that difference uh is
some somewhat clarified okay the the
primary difference is that
we are indeed freezing time if you
understand that
you you will automatically understand
that at that frozen instant of time
all the forces and constraints even if
actually they are changing with time
but once you have frozen that that is
not changing
and then you explore the changes in the
configurations of your mechanical system
respecting those particular forces
and constraints as they are at that
frozen instant of time
and then moving on further if you
consider a little infinitesimal
displacement
by keeping the time constant then what
you end up with
is the virtual infinitesimal
displacement which
is all important in the rest of our
discussions
all right with that i'll end this
lecture thank you very much